i
bom dia a todos e todas
bom a minha aspiração é mudar a escola
desde o tempo que era estudante e isso
já faz bastante tempo mas para mudar a
escola não é fácil você já ouvir os meus
colegas no exceder a dizer tudo isso e
eu também em portugal
logo depois de uma pesquisa que eu fiz
sobre o desenvolvimento da inteligência
de pessoas com deficiência intelectual
numa escola uma escola especial onde eu
trabalhei a partir de práticas de escola
comum e eu tive fiquei surpresa com os
resultados que eu consegui porque essas
pessoas com as quais eu trabalhei
a maioria delas apresentou o final de um
ano de trabalho mudanças
importantíssimas do ponto de vista
cognitivo
algumas até chegando ao pensamento
lógico concreto
essa foi uma experiência que me levou a
portugal para apresentar esse trabalho e
menezes nessa viagem
eu fui convidada a visitar uma escola de
periferia
eu fui eu achei que tinha muita coisa
diferente daquilo que eu conheci em
outras escolas no brasil mas de repente
eu vi um menino que entrou às aulas sem
braços e pernas um grande prejuízo
intelectual é que estudava
todos os demais fiquei meio sem graça
quando no final da aula depois de ter
visibilidade no a fazer todas as
atividades com os colegas e provê creio
se alimentar
eu fiquei meio chateada porque eu pedi
pra eles dançarem uma música portuguesa
e eu esqueci que o menino ia dançar com
todos mas eu tive uma surpresa que mudou
muito a minha concepção do que é uma
educação para todos
um dos colegas desse menino amarrou esse
menino no corpo e dançou com ele
isso é muito muito foi muito muito sério
para mim porque esse acolhimento no
próprio corpo e cede a tudo que a gente
poderia pensar sobre o que é estar
incluído num grupo de pessoas
então esses momentos foram muito
importantes nessa minha luta como da
escola mas muito importantes mesmo mas
eu não encontrava naquele momento em que
eu estava estudando inclusão é a escola
inserção de meninos de escola especial
em escola como tudo isso né
nesse tempo todo eu tinha eu sentia que
as pessoas tinham uma dificuldade de
entender realmente o que a inclusão que
eu precisava de uma metáfora de alguma
coisa que desce 1 sentido a inclusão que
chegasse a maioria das pessoas e com
facilidade o iene caiu nas mãos um texto
do já que de ridha de um livro chama
chamado da hospitalidade que dizer
e à hospitalidade se dá ao outro antes
mesmo que o outro se identifique
antes mesmo que ele seja um sujeito de
direito
isso pra mim foi a dica para definir
qual a metáfora que eu gostaria de usar
para explicar de fato o que é incluir e
incluir significante acesso à escola
inclusão escolar a acesso à escola
permanência na escola e participação no
processo todo porque o acesso sozinho
não adianta a permanência idem ea
participação depende da pessoa ter
rezado e permanecer dentro da escola mas
que a escola seria essa eu queria mudar
a escola o acesso incondicional à escola
é alguma coisa que tem muito a ver com a
hospitalidade em condicional e uma
imagem é essa do primeiro dia de aula a
professora com a porta da sala aberta
recebendo os alunos essa chegada dos
alunos não implicar numa seleção
anterior na sala mais forte mais fraca
nós temos um acesso incondicional
nós já temos o primeiro passo do que é a
inclusão na escola mas existe uma coisa
que é muito mais complicada e muito mais
temida de todos os estudantes que é a
permanência entra mas a ficar vai
conseguir vai ser excluído mas sair da
escola
porque não aguentou tudo que ela exige e
entram aí os estudos que nós fazemos no
meu laboratório não em camp sobre a
idéia de diferença
segundo o autor um filósofo muito
conhecido que é hoje de beleza
a diferença é o núcleo é a questão de
fundo da inclusão
a diferença de todos nós e não há
diferença de alguns diferença é muito
diferente entre de diversidade que
implica em identidades fixadas e
categorizados em grupos o grupo dos
inteligentes o grupo dos deficientes
o grupo desfavorecido o grupo dos mais
velhos dos mais moço não é isso inclusão
não tem a ver pois porque a diversidade
já como idéia existe na escola
a diferença é que é difícil porque a
diferença é ilimitada nos seres humanos
nós estamos não só somos diferentes um
do outro mas estamos nos diferenciando e
ilimitadamente
por isso somos seres singulares unívocos
que não cabe nenhuma classificação
nenhum atributo da conta do sujeito como
um todo
isso é importantíssimo a gente entender
se a gente quiser de fato fazer inclusão
inclusão não é inserir aqueles que estão
fora inclusão é pensar numa escola uma
sociedade pra todos
em uma sociedade incondicionalmente
hospitaleira bom
sua permanência então eu já disse para
vocês que ela é difícil imagine só a
permanência daqueles alunos que são
chamados alunos de inclusão como deve
ser isso é alguma coisa que a gente tem
que pensar porque a gente faz
não tô conseguindo vir aqui sem que a
gente perceba ea gente agindo assim é
excluído excluindo por comparação por
tês consideração da diferença de cada um
principalmente porque a escola é
organizada segundo a norma padrões sobre
o modelo de aluno que ela quer forma e
esse aluno existe luto é uma definição
arbitrária baseada naquilo que agente ou
que num certo momento as pessoas que têm
o poder de definir definir define como
aquele que é bom
quanto à participação que é outro ponto
muito importante
eu queria deixar claro que é preciso
mudar muito mas não é difícil se a gente
continua com essa idéia de hospedagem
com essa ideia de hospedagem
incondicional para definir o nosso
comportamento diante do outro diante de
uma instituição diante de uma sala de
aula em relação à participação o aluno é
como aquele hóspede que chega ele não
chega o cu vazio ele chega com a sua
bagagem e essa margem é muito importante
não só para ele mas para todos os que
fazem parte do grupo
porque a contribuição dele não só o
professor disponibiliza conhecimentos
numa sala de aula os alunos também eles
emitem signos signos que podem ser
palavras e idéias que podem ser imagens
que fazem com que as pessoas que estão
naquele ambiente sejam ou não afetadas
por esses meninos
por isso uma coisa muito importante
dizer que é o o professor
ele jamais garante a aprendizagem de uma
lo
isso é impossível
como ninguém motiva ninguém a motivação
é intrínseca ninguém desafia ninguém
porque se você não se sente desafiado
nada acontece
então essas idéias motiva o aluno
desafio aluno são ideias que têm a ver
com essa relação estrita dentro da
escola evidentemente entre o que o
professor ensina e o que o aluno aprende
e se ele não aprende é por que ele não
dá conta
ele precisa repetir ele precisa de
reforço
mas nem nós próprios e nem nenhum aluno
é capaz de saber quando e como aprendeu
muito menos uma avaliação numérico
conceitual
isso é tão artificial que se as pessoas
soubessem não perder o tempo com um piso
e coisas do gênero
por que as crianças brasileiras são
espertos o suficiente para dizer que eu
não quero fazer essa prova que o que eu
vou ganhar com isso
quando são submetidas ao piso não sei se
vocês
tomaram conhecimento dessa pesquisa
então vejam bem a coisa não é assim
a coisa não é assim tão prática tão
definir alto definida as coisas se
definem a partir da liberdade de cada um
de deixar que um sentido uma idéia passe
por nós e tenha um significado que pra
nós da sentido como por exemplo há
tantas coisas que a gente vive
mas poucas são aquelas que de fato nós
consideramos porque de fato contemplou e
nos dão a satisfação de uma resposta que
a gente buscava nós temos curiosidades
temos dúvidas sabemos que desconhecemos
muita coisa ea escola é um lugar pra
isso pra que o aluno leve o que ele tem
na bagagem para que ele se sinta numa
situação em que ele pode com toda a
tranquilidade resolver as suas dúvidas
já se a sua curiosidade e além do que
sabe mas pra isso ele precisa não ser
obrigado a reconhecer o que é o certo
o que o professor define como certo o
livro o currículo mas ele precisa e
espaço para reinterpretar o conhecimento
a partir das suas experiências e na sua
vida ele precisa ter um espaço para
recriar o conhecimento ele precisa ter
um espaço pra junto com o seu professor
estabelecerem de forma compartilhada e
com todos os seus colegas
uma ideia que pra ele
ou está em embrião ou ele há ainda não
conseguiu chegar até lá mas que o
incomoda e ele quer ir mais além
inclusão tem a ver com isso né inclusão
tem a ver com idéias dessa natureza por
isso é uma idéia tão revolucionária é
revolucionária porque a potência dessa
ideia pra mim é a potência que nós
precisamos de uma ideia para mudar a
escola e mudar a escola de uma forma
natural porque isso é do comportamento
humano
a escola infelizmente não a vi como
deveria porque ela é programada porque
ela é feita para que o aluno entre de um
jeito saia daquele jeito que a sociedade
exige ou espera mas as pessoas não são
assim mas podem se tornar podem se
perder nesse caminho
a inclusão é essa ideia de que o outro
existe o outro é um enigma
mas ele se comunica se comunica connosco
e se comunicando nós podemos nesse
movimento compartilhar as idéias e
compartilhar sentimentos e sem esse
compartilhamento como faremos inclusão
inclusão não é estar junto tô eu posso
estar junto muita gente no ônibus
superlotado na sala estar com é muito
diferente estar com tem a ver com
conviver
isso nos falta muito na escola poucos
conviveram com todo mundo na escola como
cada um é na sua diferença eu sendo
assim é muito difícil
a gente trabalhar com essa idéia na
escola
porém a meu ver nada é difícil quando
nós percebemos que a coisa natural
desnaturalizar uma ideia é muito mais
fácil do que se pensa
mas quando a gente de fato vive essa
ideia porque quem não vive só repete não
faz nada
não adianta só estudar
ninguém garante que está aprendendo
quando vai aprender ou se vai fazer diz
alguma coisa é preciso uma convicção e
uma convicção a gente não tenha qualquer
hora a qualquer momento uma convicção é
alguma coisa que vem de alguma situação
de algum sentimento que extrapola o
conhecimento transformar a escola gente
é mudar o sentido da escola mudar o
sentido da escola é mudar o sentido da
aula é mudar o sentido da nossa relação
com os alunos
mudar a escola é fazer naturalmente com
que a escola seja de todos
profissionalizado então não é uma tarefa
de alguns mas é uma tarefa daqueles
alguns que têm de fato essa grande
aspiração que compreenderam não só
porque se debruçar o anos lendo sobre a
matéria
então demora por isso exige persistência
por isso exige muita força e exige
principalmente que a gente tenha claro
quem é o outro como um enigma que a
gente não se lance com o professor
especificamente essa aventura de querer
fazer o impossível ou seja fazer
o outro o que a gente acha que eliéser
então se esse é um evento que ajuda as
pessoas a mudar e mudar o mundo
a inclusão é uma ideia poderosíssimo
repito pra que esse mundo mude e eu
espero que vocês possam fazer isso na
medida em que essa idéia
tome vocês já salta inflame o coração e
o conhecimento de vocês
com esta nova maneira de se fazer
educação
[Aplausos]